[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'étais assise dans ce salon dans cette
belle maison de yaoundé au cameroun où
nous habitions depuis deux ans je venais
de passer deux années à essayer de
trouver une mission un boulot un job
sans grand succès pourtant me réinventer
professionnellement je savais faire
d'ailleurs je n'avait cessé de le faire
depuis que j'avais quitté ma grosse mon
job dans ma grosse boîte au gré des
affectations de mon époux à l'étranger
pourtant ce jour là dans ce salon
j'ai dû faire ce constat que mon jour
d'après professionnels étaient bien
compromis que j'avais eu beau chercher
me réinventer professionnellement à cet
âge là était bien risqué il faut dire
aussi que j'avais vu de plus en plus
autour de moi des gens qui avaient perdu
leur job parce que trop âgés des gens
qui avaient entendu qu'il était albine
fini hors les murs hors cadre
connaissez-vous l'âgisme c'est le fait
de discriminer une personne en raison de
son âge savez-vous qu'en europe
l'âge est le premier facteur de
discrimination notamment dans le domaine
de l'emploi
selon le défenseur des droits il y
aurait deux fois plus d'expérience des
discriminations liées à l'âge que celle
dit à la couleur de peau ou aux origines
cette discrimination touche plus
sensiblement les femmes mais pour des
raisons différentes
cela vous touche vous les jeunes et nous
les moins jeunes à vous on vous dit mais
que savez vous du haut de vos 20 ans on
vous reproche votre impatience
on vous dit que vous voulez aller trop
vite à nous qu'on est trop lent pas
assez agile passé descriptif mais à vous
comme à nous quelle angoisse que de ne
pouvoir se projeter
quelle angoisse qu de ne pas pouvoir
prétendre à un avenir professionnel
de par mon métier et des différents pays
dans lesquels j'ai vécu cela m'amène à
interroger souvent nos postures nos
habitudes nos manières de faire face à
ce qu évident j'aime bien inspirer
d'autres cultures d'autres manières de
voir concernant l'avenir
par exemple si je vous demande où
plaçons-nous l'avenir quand on en parle
quelles questions devant évidemment
l'avenir c'est l'horizon que l'on voit
devant soi ce vers quoi on se projette
c'est évident universel il paraît même
que notre cerveau est conçu ainslie
évident et universel peut-être pas tant
que ça en effet en 2006 deux chercheurs
rafale une aise et eve switzer ont
découvert que les indien aymara en
amérique du sud
tournée littéralement le dos aux futurs
et faisait face au présent en joignant
même le geste à la parole
selon ces chercheurs dans le langage
aymara le monnayera signifie le passé
mais il désigne aussi la vue l'oeil le
devant des termes que nous associons
généralement au futur al'inverse le mot
guy pas signifie pour eux donc le futur
mais aussi derrière et l'arrière
attention parce que là je risque de
m'embrouiller
vous embrouiller donc je vais essayer de
simplifier quand ils disent par exemple
nairas mara qui signifie l'année
derrière il faut comprendre
l'année prochaine si j'adopte la manière
de parler des indiens imara je vous
dirai donc en joignant le geste à la
parole je vous parlerai de mes parents
de mes grands parents de mes arrières
arrières grands parents
nous on ferait plutôt ça je vous dirais
également l'année derrière lorsque vous
passerez votre diplôme
je vous souhaite de trouver un job
rapidement comment en quoi les indiens
et mara peuvent-ils nous aider parce que
c'est intéressant mais pourquoi est-ce
que je suis là alors pour le découvrir
je vous invite à faire une petite
expérience je vous propose de placer le
futur derrière votre dos de le caler là
il est bien calé la voyez c'est vraiment
le dossier de votre siège
c'est bon le futur est bien calé
derrière vous du coup que voyez-vous
devant vous je vous invite à ouvrir
grand les yeux devant ce qui constitue
votre vie je vous invite à tendre la
main vers ce premier jour du premier job
que vous avez dégoter je vous invite à
saisir le premier moment où vous avez la
première fois vous avez réussi un examen
je vous invite à visualiser la première
fois où vous êtes monté sur un vélo je
vous
et à identifier à saisir la première
fois vous avez goûté à quelque chose de
vraiment délicieux une fraise par
exemple ce faisant nous avons devant
nous plusieurs choses qu'est ce que nous
enseigne les indien aymara
à travers cette expérience premièrement
que nous sommes égaux nous sommes égaux
parce que placer sur la même ligne de
vision je vois la richesse de ma vie ce
n'est pas rien 20 ans pour vous de vie
s'est fait de fabuleux moments tout
comme mes 50 ans ils sont aussi
constitués de plein de première fois
donc il nous enseigne que nous sommes
égaux lorsque l'on se positionne ainsi
le dos au futur et le passé devant nous
cette manière de voir les choses nous
rend plus forts parce que
individuellement et collectivement en
ayant cette clairvoyance de ce qui a
fait que nous sommes là aujourd'hui de
ce qui nous constitue nous sommes mieux
armés
justement pour affronter l'avenir mais
les indiens imara nous enseigne quelque
chose de beaucoup plus simple il nous
enseigne le bon sens de la route
en effet lorsque l'on conduit c'est tout
de même plus simple d'avoir la route
devant soi que derrière avec les indiens
mara on n'a plus besoin de se tordre le
cou pour regarder notre passé on n'a
plus besoin de fermer les yeux pour se
souvenir des choses on a tous devant
nous donc finalement le pragmatisme des
indiens mara est quelque chose qui peut
nous aider à plusieurs niveaux en
adoptant cette posture
je n'ai plus peur de l'avenir j'ai pu
voir devant moi mes ambitions et mes
rêves
plus exploré toute la richesse de mes
expériences de vie j'ai pu aussi
parcourir mais échec ce que j'ai
surmonté
est ce que je n'ai pas su remonter mais
en somme la posture d un mondial marat
m'a vraiment permis de prendre une
décision qui était celle de quitter le
cameroun de revenir en france afin d'y
construire un avenir à ma mesure les
indiens et mara nous aide aussi pour
l'innovation
j'anime des ateliers d'innovation avec l
j'utilise cette posture parce qu après
tout qu'est-ce qu'une innovation
quand on y songe c'est une solution à un
problème qui n'a pas été résolu dans le
passé idem pour les innovations de
rupture pour pouvoir être discuté il
faut être clairvoyant sur ce qui a
marché ce qui n'a pas marché
avoir une bonne vision du timing mais
cette posture peut être naturelle à tout
le monde elle ne l'est pas au départ
mais elle peut être pour tout le monde
par exemple que vous ayez 25 ans ou 55
ans lorsque dans un entretien
professionnel par exemple et qu'on vous
demande de vous projeter dans les cinq
prochaines années beaucoup d'entre nous
on n'a pas idée de ce que l'on souhaite
faire on n'a pas idée de ce que l'on
souhaite devenir ou être au lieu de vous
projeter dans cet avenir qui est un
petit peu obscur je vous propose au
contraire de vous projeter dans votre
passé
projetez-vous n'en veut se passer voyez
vos rêves de gosse voyez ce qui vous a
donné envie de vous réveiller chaque
matin pour changer le monde ou
simplement pour voir le sourire des gens
qui vous sont chers ce que l'on voit
devant soi lorsque l'on tourne le dos à
l'avenir
c'est ce que nous sommes profondément
dans la plénitude de ce que nous
deviendrons demain
c'est pour cela que je vous souhaite à
tous un très bel avenir derrière vous
[Applaudissements]